cinq objectifs pour un avenir proposer
un cadre de vie agréable ou encore
préserver la biodiversité
voilà les ambitions des ateliers
concertation entre mort d'asia les
citoyens étaient conviés lundi en mairie
à réfléchir sur le projet d'aménagement
et de développement durable intégré au
plan local d'urbanisme la parole des
habitants est importante si ce sont eux
qui vivent je pense qu'ils peuvent
prendre parti au débat et comment du
coup on intègre la fois la croissance de
la ville et une biodiversité plus
importante donner la parole aux
principaux intéressés permet aux élus à
terme de proposer un plan local
d'urbanisme adaptés aux besoins des
habitants plus on est personnes à
réfléchir sur un projet plus on peut
espérer que le projet sera de qualité
donc qu'on ait des gens qui viennent de
d'horizons divers et variés ça peut
apporter des débuts des vues de jeunes
par exemple sont pas obligatoirement
exactement les vues d'un la retraitée
donc l'idée c'est de justement met des
des verrous met des des barrières pour
empêcher justement une urbanisation
lombez année avec 44 5% des espaces
forestiers et naturel maurepas possède
un fort potentiel son attractivité et
son accessibilité ont animé les ateliers
ont fait une nouvelle construction
d'associer les habitants du quartier
pour l'histoire de la folie tu es aussi
dans la mobilité le projet d'aménagement
et de développement durable sera débattu
en décembre lors du prochain conseil
municipal